[Música]
un placer saludarlos en el debate de
France 24 Mi nombre es Ángela Gómez el
presidente de Ucrania boludo y
mercedesky retornó a su país después de
una gira europea que lo llevó a Italia
El Vaticano Alemania Francia y también a
Reino Unido fueron tres días en los que
los líderes renovaron sus promesas de
apoyo y también de armas así reaccionó
el mandatario tras un vanguardeo Ruso a
la capital ucraniana al llegar a su país
después de su gira
Antes que nada Quiero agradecer a todos
los defensores de nuestros cielos
Gracias Héroes 18 de los 18 misiles
fueron derribados es por eso que estamos
trabajando constantemente en visitas que
traerán más oportunidades más sistemas
una y otra vez agradezco a todos
nuestros socios en el mundo que han
ayudado a nuestro país con los sistemas
de defensa aérea adecuados
ayer también acordamos en Gran Bretaña
con el Primer Ministro Richie sunak que
trabajaríamos en una coalición de
aviones de combate entrenamiento y
aeronaves ayer esto también fue
respaldado por el presidente francés
macron y hoy lo fue por el Primer
Ministro de Países Bajos marrut un buen
comienzo para la coalición Gracias a
todos
precisamente del tema que nos convoca en
este debate es el análisis sobre los
últimos movimientos de zelenski y su
incidencia en la guerra que Ucrania
Libra contra Rusia que está en el debate
sobre todo por los últimos movimientos y
las acusaciones que hay de parte y parte
de Cara a la fortaleza bélica para ello
nos acompañan Juan Manuel Portilla quien
es doctor en derecho internacional y
profesor de la Facultad de Estudios
Superiores a catalanes de la Universidad
Nacional de México también se conecta
con nosotros a Marcela chapa Garza ella
es directora de la escuela de relaciones
internacionales de la Universidad
Anáhuac de Querétaro Ya regreso con
ustedes a nuestros invitados para las
preguntas pero antes quisiera
recordarles a nuestros televidentes sé
que también ustedes hacen parte de este
debate por favor déjennos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba France 24 guión bajo es la
etiqueta es el numeral el debate f24 y a
mí me encuentran en Twitter como Ángela
Go f24 no olviden tampoco que todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y también en TuneIn se abre
este debate
Pues bien Vamos a dar inicio a las
preguntas sin más demora Juan Manuel
quiero comenzar con usted porque cada
vez se le veas el esquí más activo
internacionalmente donde radica la
importancia de esta última gira que
presenciamos de tres días
Bueno pues es muy importante el que
tenga esta actividad diplomática toda
vez que pues es para él vital y urgente
conseguir apoyos financiamiento que se
ha estado dando Y bueno pues la búsqueda
de mayor armamento no que tampoco es
fácil porque de alguna manera Hay cierta
reticencia no obstante que se
suministran armamentos y se prometen
muchas cosas porque tampoco se quiere
llegar a un extremo de provocar
demasiado Rusia y bueno no olvidemos que
no se puede no se puede traspasar ese
límite de la otan digamos no no puede
haber tropas de la otan directamente
implicadas lo más que se puede hacer es
un apoyo de tipo de armamento y
financiero Pero igualmente también hay
un peligro de escalada nuclear el propio
el propio presidente Putin ha señalado
En diversas ocasiones que incluso no
dudarían emplear más nucleares en caso
de que hubiera una escalada mayor
entonces bueno estas son tanto el
escenario no en el que es que pues ha
sido muy activo diplomáticamente muy
mediático y bueno ha acudido a las
principales capitales europeas en busca
de este apoyo aunque también hay se
distingue cierta diferencia entre entre
los aliados no entre Alemania la propia
Francia por un lado pero en este caso el
Reino Unido pareciera estar más
dispuesto a proporcionar este algún
equipo superior ya de combate incluso
aviones casa que esto no se han
suministrado sean limitado a la entrega
de de misiles y de tanques este de la
Última Generación por parte de los
miembros de la otan pues sobre ello
quisiera que discutiéramos más adelante
para revisar a qué se comprometió cada
país pero Marcela también quiero
preguntarle a usted sobre la importancia
de este viaje Porque si viene Juan
Manuel nos hablaba de las limitaciones
que tienen los miembros de la otan y de
la Unión Europea para brindar su apoyo
en la Guerra de Ucrania Pues sí se ve el
flujo constante pero pero esto se ha
visto desde el inicio de la guerra Cuál
es la diferencia ahora que se le esquivó
capital por capital
Pues creo que
la intensidad del viaje no de de de
todas las ciudades este en en tres días
intentando comprometer lo que
públicamente dice que pide no O sea Creo
que creo que es una cosa muy importante
no han sido negociaciones a Puerta
cerrada no O sea todo ha sido como muy
público como decía justamente el doctor
Portilla y y que y con una agenda como
muy marcada no va por por decía que iba
por armas por defensa aérea por el tema
de la reconstrucción este que fue lo que
pactó con con mayor fuerza en con Italia
o el tema de la del de la pertenencia a
la a la Unión Europea y a la otan este
inseguridad no entonces como que creo
que esas son los Los ejes que él marcó
en esta en esta gira y pues nada también
también Creo que importante entender que
el empuje que que está intentando darle
a a Europa para que Europa se comprometa
de alguna manera más eh Hay gente que
habla de que
anticipándose a la posible
Victoria digamos republicana en Estados
Unidos y eso es lo que puede implicar
tiene que de alguna manera este asegurar
desde antes un poquito más de apoyo de
la Unión Europea que que como también
bien decía el doctor Portilla el el
Reino Unido había estado como más firme
inclusive desde desde cuando estaba
Boris Johnson en en el gobierno y este y
y la Unión Europea pues había había
tenido como sus sus reticencias y su
historial y también Italia Pues de
alguna manera con con la nueva este
administración de melón Y pues meloni
también se ve este comprometida melón y
fue a a a a Ucrania hace tiempo y Y eso
también hace que la el hecho de que haya
habido tanto cambio de mandatarios en en
en este en estos meses Pues también
necesitaba como reafianzar amistades y y
compromisos No claro eso es entendible
en el caso de Italia pero del Reino
Unido Aunque si viene pasaron de Boris
Johnson a Richi zonak
definitivamente desde los británicos es
desde donde probablemente han venido
unos mensajes con mayor fuerza de apoyo
y y mayores promesas de ir a negociar
con los demás miembros de la Unión
Europea de hecho Richie suna que dijo en
esta jornada que conversaría en la
Cumbre con la Unión Europea sobre sobre
reposicionar O cambiar y aumentar el
foco de la ayuda hacia Ucrania ustedes
ven que se dé Próximamente lo que usted
plantea o Juan Manuel y es la entrega de
aviones de combate porque selensky ha
hecho este pedido una y otra vez en el
curso de los últimos dos meses
Bueno a mí me parece que en algún punto
sí se hará entrega no sabemos En qué
número pero yo creo que sí se hará
entrega de lo que entiendo también
ofreció sunat que es capacitar a los
pilotos ucranianos toda vez que estamos
hablando de equipos de alta
sofisticación de Última Generación y de
momento parece que también antes de ello
estarían suministrando una serie de de
capacitación de entrenamiento no para
efecto de poder tripular y y poder
operar debidamente este este tipo de de
aviones no Y también yo creo que hay un
compás de espera en tanto que se
resuelven ciertas situaciones que tanto
es la respuesta de Rusia
se va un tanto con cierta precaución con
cierta lentitud pero bueno sí se aprecia
que en el caso del Reino Unido quizá con
este gobierno de sunat si notamos que
hay un protagonismo importante
quizá también trata de compensar esos
que tuvo por el brexit Y de alguna
manera pues sí sí está ejerciendo pues
una especie de papel protagónico
distinto a sus contrapartes de de Europa
continental Me parece que sí si el caso
del Reino Unido sí está está más
posicionado en este en estas promesas y
y en caso de llevarse a cabo de
suministro de equipo me parece bueno y
Marcela una pregunta que se ha
convertido en una muy recurrente Durante
los últimos meses sobre todo yo diría
Durante los últimos seis meses y es
hasta qué punto la entrega de este o tal
armamento va a cambiar el ritmo o el
curso de la guerra Entonces el último
anuncio de Reino Unido tenía que ver con
la entrega de misiles de largo alcance
ahora Estamos viendo la posibilidad de
que finalmente den su brazo a torcer
algunos miembros de la Unión Europea con
los aviones de combate cambia el ritmo
de la guerra
no sé si cambia el ritmo de la guerra
cambia digamos pues ciertas capacidades
que que son reales no y Y eso tiene que
ver pues con también con con los
compromisos de entrenamiento este y y
creo que también en el tema de de
Alemania hay un compromiso económico
este pues que que reafirman más fuerte
pero eh creo que también esto tiene que
ver con con las percepciones de de las
alianzas geopolíticas y y esto de que de
que se haga tan público todo También
necesita que que haya digamos que que la
moral de del pueblo de Ucrania no muera
entonces creo que eso es lo más
importante en esta guerra de alguna
manera el elemento humano a mí siempre
se me ha hecho este como muy relevante
porque para los rusos este es una guerra
que digamos lo voy a hacer una
caricatura de de la situación pero pero
es una guerra de su líder y algunos la
la cuestionan y y algunos inclusive
soldados como de por qué estamos
peleando esto cuando para los ucranianos
esto es su territorio esto es vital esto
es este nada Digamos como como como como
desde una parte humana mucho más
aguerrida con mucho más sentido este
para la moral del de las tropas no
entonces Creo que este es una cosa Este
importante que que consideremos bueno
pero Juan Manuel esta esta dialéctica
alrededor de la entrega de aviones de
combate Ucrania se parece mucho a la que
vivimos hace unos meses con los tanques
Leppard No que inicialmente los líderes
europeos y también Estados Unidos
dijeron que no iban a entregar este tipo
de armamento Ucrania y finalmente sí se
terminó concediendo
Por qué Porque digamos esta atención o
esta presión inicial o esta reticencia a
entregar el armamento si finalmente van
a terminar Armando a Ucrania es decir
hay alguna diferencia entre hablar de
tanques y hablar de aviones o
simplemente porque este manejo de los
líderes occidentales
bueno hablar ya de de casas bombarderos
de de largo alcance me parece a mí
también misiles eh que se han estado
proporcionando como los Stone Shadow por
parte del Reino Unido me parece a mí que
sí tiene alguna relevancia no Alemania
dio un paso adelante con la entrega de
estos leopard también hubo los
Challenger por parte de los británicos y
hay también entregas y Promesa de abrams
por parte de Estados Unidos Yo creo que
si hace una diferencia que se
proporcionaran este aviones de combate
Porque estos pues evidentemente tienen
un alcance mayor podrían tener una
cobertura más grande o incluso poder
también alcanzar objetivos dentro de
Rusia no también hay que decir que hasta
ahora la guerra se ha limitado entre los
límites de ucranianos no obstante que
hay una larga frontera y Que bueno hay
territorios ya ocupados lo más que llegó
a ver fue una un dron por ahí que se
aproximaba Moscú Pero bueno de alguna
manera pues también este paso de
proporcionar si hay alguna diferencia yo
creo que
se ha llegado un punto después de un año
y meses de esta guerra que es una
especie de administrar el conflicto no
Mientras hay intentos diplomáticos
tampoco se puede aflojar mucho la
entrega de armamento Ucrania porque no
no combina occidente que hay una derrota
pero al mismo tiempo Rusia tampoco se
rinde Y si bien Rusia no cuenta con una
economía muy fuerte es un país de
mediana economía Pues sí tiene un
armamento que le permitiría sostener
esta guerra e incluso el armamento
nuclear Entonces yo creo que se está
llegando a un en un punto en el que de
cierta forma vale decir que se está
administrando la guerra no obstante otro
tipo de esfuerzos no como por ejemplo lo
que se ha hecho en la Corte Penal
Internacional condenando a Putin por
ejemplo por crímenes de guerra y a su y
a suya la señora leoba que es la que
administra la la infancia en Ucrania por
traslado de menores y otros crímenes Y
bueno ya se han señalado varios y
diversos crímenes en otros órganos como
el parlamento europeo Entonces yo creo
que ahí hay un juego entre entre
mantener el equilibrio de las fuerzas y
la guerra pero al mismo tiempo una serie
de esfuerzos diplomáticos e incluso
institucionales Bueno pero en ese
sentido Hace algunos días se lensky
declaraba que todavía le faltaban
algunos detalles Juan Manuel para lanzar
esta prometida y tan alargada contra
ofensiva de primavera estuvo ya
visitando los países europeos Usted cree
que fue para conseguir lo que le faltaba
Bueno sí que lo haya logrado o no del
todo porque bueno no no regresa con las
manos vacías sí trae ya digamos más
suministro de armamento pero sobre todo
lo que trae más son promesas no en
cierto modo este ya la primavera está
pues avanzada y esta contraofensiva Pues
de alguna manera trata de guardar el
equilibrio pero yo creo que que no se
logra todavía si no se contaría con más
con más armamento no ha habido
territorios de Ucrania que se toman y
que se recuperan Entonces yo creo que
está un punto hay un impasse no Incluso
en este conflicto bélico del cual no se
no se definen las posiciones y Bueno
zelensky pues acudió con esta llamado de
auxilio y de cooperación y quizás
regresó con un 60% de lo que pretendía
no obstante los discursos muy positivos
que se señalan de alguna manera para
inyectar cierto optimismo no Pero bueno
no no se logró todo lo que se esperaba
tampoco bueno y aquí la siguiente
pregunta quisiera hacerla para los dos
comenzando con nuestra invitada porque
claro usted hablaba Juan Manuel de los
diferentes frentes en los que se está
librando la guerra Entonces está el
frente bélico está el frente diplomático
están las acciones ante cortes
internacionales etcétera etcétera Pero
pero llegados a este punto en el que se
entrega cada vez más armamento y no hay
avances significativos en la guerra
estamos hablando de metros conquistados
en bajó durante las últimas semanas
porque entre otras cosas Estados Unidos
y los socios occidentales no han forzado
junto con sus aliados que es el esquí
negocie la paz y que Ucrania al final de
cuentas pierda algo de terreno pero que
pueda detenerse el flujo de la guerra
pregunto primero para usted Marcela
Pues creo que de alguna manera se lensky
lo dejó claro desde el principio no que
que el tema territorial es es uno de sus
no negociables y no ha cambiado de
opinión hasta ahorita entonces Creo que
creo que si hubiese habido más daño por
parte de de Rusia que eso también nos ha
hablado de pues una cierta capacidad de
contención importante este de parte de
Ucrania Eh pues tal vez estudiemos en
otro momento pero no lo estamos no y
tampoco estamos en en en en en en en
este momento de de en que ya solamente
existiera la posibilidad de de la paz a
través de negociaciones Todavía este se
puede prolongar y Y todavía se puede
administrar como es el doctor Portilla
el el el la cantidad este de armamento
que que se utiliza y la capacidad del
militares de parte de los dos este
precisamente por eso porque porque
el el el el el el la digamos ha sido una
guerra compleja pero no ha sido
devastadora de parte de ninguna de las
dos y eso ha permitido que se que se
pueda alargar pero no hay condiciones
para negociación de hecho tenemos pues
pues a varios países que se han que se
han este voluntariado Digamos como como
como como intentos de mediación
inclusive El Vaticano que fue uno de los
que de los que visitó muy al principio
este tenemos el el el el la complejidad
de la geopolítica el elemento chino no
de de la relación que que que de alguna
manera China y Rusia tienen como mucho
más fuerte pero que a lo largo de de
estos meses pues se ha visto que que
china ha estado intentando cambiar y y
se ha intentado poner como como el
mediador posible y sacando Europa de la
ecuación Pero entonces a Europa también
ha querido decir aquí estamos Este y eso
ha hecho que que las conversaciones sean
multilaterales y mucho más complejas sin
que haya un liderazgo serio muy fuerte
tenemos varios liderazgos tenemos varios
compromisos tenemos varios niveles y
varios tipos de de compromiso de
distintos actores pero no tenemos a
alguien que ahorita veamos como como el
el pivote clave por lo mismo porque
porque la complejidad de las relaciones
internacionales y geopolíticas del día
de hoy es tal que ha sido difícil que
que encontremos quién quién marque la
Pauta para para liderar las
negociaciones No claro y le entiendo lo
que usted me dice porque se le es que ha
sido como mencionaba muy claro en decir
que no va a ceder terreno pero la verdad
es que se le esqui por sí mismo no puede
sostener la guerra en Ucrania necesita
el apoyo de los aliados occidentales Y
si bien hay varios frentes abiertos pues
está la otan no y y está Estados Unidos
como gran líder Pues de este organismo y
en esta guerra entonces lo que lo que lo
que quisiera que aclaráramos es porque
todavía el interés de mantenerle
mantener el enfrentamiento bélico Pues
de parte de los aliados occidentales al
final
en ese sentido creo que por en el al
principio no podían ser tan tajantes con
con Rusia por todavía las dependencias
económicas que existían
subimos que tuvimos que el tema del gas
el tema de los commodities todo eso se
tardó mucho tiempo en en en reconfigurar
y creo que esa es una parte de la
respuesta Juan Manuel veía que no no
estaba de acuerdo cuando estábamos
conversando cuéntenos Cuál es su opinión
bueno no no del todo decir este lo que
yo aquí quisiera señalar es que bueno
por supuesto así coincido con Marcela
con la maestra chapa en cuanto que
Celeste ha sido muy enfático en que no
se debería territorio estamos hablando
de que también sería un tanto reconocer
que los territorios se pueden conquistar
es contrario al derecho internacional a
la carta de la ONU mismo México ha
sufrido por ejemplo y otros países este
tipo de pérdidas territoriales que de
alguna manera son contrarias al derecho
internacional sin embargo yo creo que
por esta guerra bueno viene desde el
2014 cuando cuando se toma crimea no y
sebastopol y toda esa parte quizá esa
parte sí está ya perdida No por parte de
Ucrania porque han pasado muchos años y
no se ha podido recuperar Aunque nadie
lo reconoce no esa parte del territorio
hay que recordar también que que crimea
había sido ruso allá cuando la unión
soviética que el pueblo le cedió esta
parte a Ucrania entonces también ahí hay
un antecedente histórico no y es una
parte vital también para para Rusia
mantener esa base en sebastopol que lo
convierte en una potencia mediterránea
no esa salida al mar Negro es muy
importante importantísima esa salida de
Rusia por ejemplo también kaliningrado
que lo mantiene allá en el Báltico que
es una parte ahí esa península que
tampoco se dio nunca Rusia no no
obstante que es una especie de enclave
rodeado por otros territorios para yo
también creo que el reconocer
territorios o exceder territorios a
cambio de paz también es un precedente
peligroso porque por ejemplo Georgia
también tiene territorios este rusos o
repúblicas rusas ahí desde hace tiempo
No incluso hubo una hubo una guerra con
apoyo de tropas rusas no ahí para
efectos de
Sur también está tan siniestra que es
esta parte de moldoba que es una
República autoproclamada rusa entonces
bueno yo creo que la región del Don vas
que y el resto de territorios ocupados
que no vas a no más allá de un 15% pues
es difícil sin Yo creo que la medida en
que hubiera una presión occidental que
la guerra se prolongara más y que no
hubiera una Clara definición a favor de
Ucrania militarmente tal vez lo que
podría ya reconocerse y cederse por
parte de Ucrania con la presión
internacional sería la parte solamente
de crimea yo creo que la de las del don
más difícilmente no me parece que no no
podría
desprenderse de tanto territorio Ucrania
no Y además Rusia bueno Rusia qué
tendría que que ceder Bueno ya tuvo
grandes pérdidas materiales y humanas Y
de alguna manera pues Rusia no podría
irse con las manos vacías después de
haberse embarcado en esta guerra que yo
pienso que calculaba que iba a ser más
rápida no que no iba a durar tanto ahora
ha habido efectos que no deseaba Rusia
que Rusia deseaba evitar una expansión
de la otan sin embargo Finlandia que
había sido neutral pues ya ya ingresó a
la otan en estos tratos mismos está está
Suecia entonces de alguna manera pues
también si lo que pretendía Rusia era
que no avanzara la otan con estos nuevos
miembros sobre todo del Oeste pues lo
está está logrando su objetivo contrario
no la ampliación de la otan y con lo
cual pues ya la frontera con la otan
este cada vez es mayor y en varios
flancos por parte de Rusia bueno mire
que justamente sobre ceder terreno
crimea es la que eleva la gran pregunta
porque si usted tiene razón y está en
contra del derecho internacional está en
contra de todo lo que podrían o deberían
permitir desde occidente y desde Ucrania
sin embargo pues también hay analistas
que no descartan esta posibilidad dado
que ya va más de un año de guerra y pues
no se ven Muchos avances en el terreno
por otro lado Juan Manuel y también a
nuestra invitada Marcela se leensky en
un su parada en Alemania le propuso Olaf
shows que se uniera más activamente a la
coalición militar que apoya a los
ucranianos Alemania ha dado un apoyo que
pasó de cascos a después apoyos un poco
más más grandes con el paso del tiempo
hacia kiev pero aún se mantiene digamos
muy al margen no A diferencia de una
postura como la de Reino Unido que ha
sido Clara desde el principio
haría una mayor implicación alemana por
ejemplo la diferencia en la guerra y
pues lo mismo para Emanuel macron que
promete ahora entrenar más soldados
ucranianos y apoyar también con más
munición
Bueno yo pienso que Alemania es más
cauta por su cercanía geográfica como
sea el Reino Unido tiene una distancia
mayor eh de alguna manera no está está
lejos todavía el escenario de guerra en
términos de territoriales y no es así el
caso de Alemania que además ya sufrió
Las mayores consecuencias en una guerra
de este tipo no y bueno de todos modos
pues la mayor potencia económica es
Alemania y también quizás subyace ahí
alguna cuestión de la dependencia de los
energéticos de rusos todavía no del gas
y de sobre todo no el qué otro tipo de
elementos energéticos que hace que en
cierto modo
Alemania sea más cauto tal vez por estas
circunstancia no no obstante que de
todos modos Italia y la misma Francia
pues van por otro lado y el reino y
Francia pero yo creo que en mi opinión
hace la diferencia es una cuestión más
bien geopolítica no geográfica
estrictamente en cuanto que Alemania
tiene sus fronteras más cercanas no
al escenario de guerra y a la propia
Rusia gracias gracias y Marcela
precisamente viendo digamos las
diferentes posturas que uno puede
encontrar en la Unión Europea frente a
Ucrania hoy se conoció la noticia de
Hungría que decidió bloquear el
desembolso de un próximo tramo de apoyo
militar para Ucrania y que se iba a
entregar a través del fondo europeo para
la paz no entonces Hungría sostiene que
estos fondos no deberían concentrarse
única y exclusivamente en Ucrania que
hay otros lugares que también son de
interés de la Unión Europea como los
balcanes como el norte de África ustedes
qué opinan de ese razonamiento y de ese
bloqueo que imponen algunos de los
miembros
Pues creo que precisamente la la
respuesta europea fue lenta por eso por
por porque cada uno tiene algunos
intereses la eterna historia de de si la
Unión Europea tiene que reaccionar este
conjuntamente en su política exterior y
hemos visto que de alguna manera Ese ha
sido este uno de las grandes Eh pues
impedimentos y y y y grandes faltas que
que ha tenido a pesar de que de que
úrsulayer ha intentado simbólicamente
este estar estar presente y y apoyar
Pues creo que a la hora de del apoyo
material es cuando es cuando vemos Esta
fragmentación de intereses de
dependencias este con con Rusia en este
en este caso de de Pues sí el el tema
energético no es menor el tema de de
simpatías políticas entonces Este creo
que eso hace que que nos demos cuenta
que el el la Pues digamos la variedad de
de intereses al interno de la Unión
Europea se se muestran
en en en en en en los compromisos de
cada uno y creo que también por eso se
les cogió específicamente a estos países
no en en la gira de alguna manera como
ya decíamos este Reino Unido intentando
diferenciarse de la de la política de la
Unión Europea con con un poquito más de
protagonismo pero también este el
gobierno nuevo de Italia ha intentado
este ha intentado desmarcarse digamos de
de amistades que que que que que antes
existían de Cara a los líderes con Putin
porque de alguna manera pues el el el el
el la persistencia del personaje Putin
en en en en tantos años Pues también
tiene tiene mucha historia este y bueno
nada Creo que creo que es Es normal que
encontremos
diferencias y también Es normal que
encontremos lentitud en las respuestas
europeas siempre en política exterior
por esto pero sea muere Marcela el
armamento sí está en el centro de las
conversaciones como lo ha estado siempre
el ministro de defensa ruso sergeiju
Este martes
desestimó la afirmación de Ucrania que
dijo que en los últimos días ha
derribado sus misiles y Supersónicos que
según Rusia eran absolutamente
imparables se supone que de ser momento
pues era una de las grandes novedades
que entregaba Rusia o que aportaba a
Rusia dentro de la guerra y de los
combates Porque tanto protagonismo a los
ataques con este armamento selenski como
veíamos al inicio del programa dando las
gracias por los sistemas de defensa
antiaderos que ha proveído occidente por
ejemplo
sí Bueno Este creo que el el
El Fuerte ha sido el el el el el como
como bien decías no ha habido gran eh
armamento de de de de alto alcance pues
lo que sí ha habido ha sido antimisiles
y y y y ha sido como para protección
también una de las cosas que han hecho
ha sido marcar como muy claramente que
es para la protección absoluta y en el
territorialmente tendría que ser este
solamente para proteger a a a al
territorio ucraniano de de la invasión
no deseada no entonces creo que por ahí
están
haciendo como digamos un un Empalme del
discurso este de no provocar de más a
Rusia este con armamento que por ahora
sea como muy digamos de defensa en en
ese sentido
pues miren yo les agradezco a los dos ya
nos estamos acercando al final del
programa Así que quisiera pedirles a
ambos un poco sus conclusiones y además
que cuenten para los televidentes para
ustedes Cuáles son los frutos de esta
gira Europea de celes que comienzo con
Juan Manuel Bueno yo quisiera agregar
que esta visita también de alguna manera
demuestra un tanto la diversidad que
tiene la Unión Europea sin duda Pues el
ensky eligió bien las capitales a las
que había que acudir los líderes con los
que tenía que entrevistar se verá con
shorts con con macron con el propio este
Primer Ministro británico entonces de
alguna manera me parece que el balance
es un tanto positivo aunque también
demuestra las diferencias que hay al
interior en la Unión Europea digo es el
caso por ejemplo de Hungría que es el
país menos democrático está como al
margen casi de la Unión Europea no
entonces de alguna manera pues eso
también hace que en cierto modo busque
cierta complacencia con Moscú Entonces
yo creo que
esto pues sin duda es una es una
victoria diplomática que no se traduce
necesariamente en resultados militares a
corto plazo y había que verlo con esa
expectativa también no no no no tampoco
implica que esto va a significar un
apoyo total y definitivo por parte de la
otan Y estos países es complicado
y Marcela pues veamos entonces Cuáles
son para usted los frutos de esta gira
de zelensky tres días Muy rápidamente
varias capitales en varios jefes de
estado y de gobierno pero que al final
tampoco entregaron un mensaje muy
diferente al que se ha mantenido en
coherencia desde el inicio de la guerra
Sí claro creo que para mí fue afianzar
un compromiso que se notaba ante la
opinión pública como más tibio y decir
que después de un año y y meses está
cada vez más sólido pero con pasos
digamos este lentos y por otra parte
creo que otro de los frutos es que está
a pensar en la reconstrucción no eso no
lo tocamos en estos momentos pero pero
creo que también un el compromiso de
Italia por ejemplo militarmente fue este
digamos raquítico pero sí hubo un un
compromiso que que está respaldado con
ya una conferencia que había este Italia
realizado con empresarios este italianos
para este los proyectos de
reconstrucción y para los proyectos de
de infraestructura entonces creo que
también es esa es una de las de las de
las ganancias que que se ha tenido de
las que se habla poco bueno Marcela pero
quiero que sería bueno antes de
despedirnos de todas maneras que don
dáramos un poco más en este tema y veo
que lo ha mencionado varias veces
Durante este debate es bueno hablar de
eso no cómo van a de todas maneras a
financiar los países europeos la
reconstrucción de Ucrania eso ha sido
una discusión de ires y venir se ha
dicho incluso que Rusia tendría que
pagar a los costos de la guerra lo cual
legalmente tampoco ha probado ser algo
muy funcional Entonces cómo sería el
papel de Italia pues al hacer estos
compromisos que se alejan un poco de lo
bélico de los colegas de la Unión
Europea Pues sí creo que creo que la
agenda de melón y tiene este un poquito
esta este nacionalismo de de volver a
ser Italia este una nación grande
próspera económicamente y tal entonces
la la reactivación de de alguno de sus
sectores a través de este el apoyo a la
reconstrucción evidentemente ahí tendría
que ser como muy estratégico de Cara a
los fondos y que tanto la Unión Europea
lo va a lograr Y qué tanto va a ser
digamos a crédito este a largo plazo
para para tanto Ucrania como como para
este digamos países que quisieran
aportar a esta reconstrucción y crear
fondos comunes que que sí lo veo este
suceder en en un futuro pero creo que de
alguna manera Esa es la ganancia que que
que que que que que Italia tiene para
para su propio país no que que sería una
promesa al interno que a lo mejor se
ejecuta o no este pero pero de
porque te digo que ya ya hizo un unas
reuniones este con con con con digamos
en con altos empresarios este para para
poder analizar la posibilidad de
de inyectar digamos al a la economía
italiana desde el el sector de la
construcción viene y creo que nos queda
tiempo para Una última pregunta para
Juan Manuel porque el más reciente
paquete que entregaría la Unión Europea
sería de 2.700 son millones de euros
provenientes del grupo Qué espera de
Europa Juan Manuel en su opinión que
suceda con la guerra al sostener la
financiación por más tiempo después de
este año y algunos meses
Bueno yo creo que es difícil que también
comprometan más recursos de alguna
manera sino hay una definición
bélica digamos en algunos meses yo creo
que no se sostendrá este límite este
este ritmo no de de apoyo además también
ha habido exigencias en términos de la
del gobierno en Ucrania no que de alguna
manera también ha tenido tintes de de
corrupción y de algunas cuestiones de
prácticas no muy
transparentes Y de alguna manera también
Creo que estará condicionado a esto no
un poco el comportamiento ya de la
estructura de gobierno del propio
Ucrania pero Bueno finalmente No creo
que se sostenga por mucho tiempo Esto
fue estos flujos de caja tan importantes
no no creo que por mucho tiempo se
sostengan Y eso estará orillando Ucrania
Pues a negociar Finalmente y tal vez
acceder este o reconocer ya por la
primera no y que esto trajera ya la pase
definitivamente Pues muy bien soneo Juan
Manuel Portilla doctor en derecho
internacional y profesores de la
facultad de Estudios Superiores de
Acatlán de la Universidad Nacional de
México y también Marcela chapa Garza
quien es la directora de la escuela de
relaciones internacionales de la
Universidad de Anáhuac Muchas gracias a
nuestros invitados por el panorama que
nos dan porque al final pues Seguiremos
haciendo la revisión y el
correspondiente seguimiento de lo que
sucede en la guerra gracias a ambos
así llegamos al final de este debate
ustedes sigan con nosotros en France 24
la producción del programa estuvo a
cargo de Andrés doncell y la producción
de los invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera ha sido un placer acompañarlos
nos vemos próximamente
[Música]